it was to put it mildly a celebration of
the very thing the American right has
turned into its latest anti-wokness
Boogeyman diversity equity and inclusion
host Trevor Noah walked and talked
through a room that was diversity equity
and inclusion in human form
the first country Americana artist to
perform Brandy Carlisle was introduced
by her wife and daughters
we saw the first trans artist when a
Grammy Kim Petras who has a hit song
with Sam Smith the culture wars are over
and the left one like total defeat
actually lady you literally cannot win
because of our founding documents you
are a racist what you care about most is
the color of a singer's skin you're
obsessed with their racial makeup and
their ethnic background and their
sexuality and whether they chop their
genitals off and you think that's
winning